it's always so much fun kim kardashian
is having so much fun
spreading some holiday cheer it was such
an exciting thing
the reality star hit up twitter monday
to reveal that she's partnered up with
cash app to send straight cash to fans
who've been struggling amid the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic
she explained quote hey guys 2020 has
been hard and many are worried about
paying rent or putting food on their
table
i want to spread the love by sending 500
to 1000 people
yeah that's 500 000 total
okay i think i can do that but this is
just the latest for kimmy claus who's
been keeping the holiday spirit alive at
home
it's really fun to see after the
kardashian jetter crew announced
that they wouldn't be hosting their
annual christmas eve bash this year due
to the rising coronavirus cases in
california
kim shared clips to her insta story from
a very merry
very tipsy kardashian jenner
pre-christmas dinner
yeah that's kim channeling her inner
brandy and monica
circa 1998 with her mom kris jenner's
longtime beau corey gamble
and there's kim again posing with santa
while her big
sis kourtney kardashian hides behind the
chair with a stick pony
[Music]
wow he wasn't lions i wasn't lying it's
not a lie
it wasn't me
[Music]
the reality star admitted she was so
deep in the sauce
she didn't even remember taking those
epic videos
it's so crazy the proud mom of four also
took her kiddos ice skating and covered
all the trees in her lawn with twinkly
christmas lights
i swear i'm really good i'm really
really good
and if that wasn't enough earlier this
month kim revealed how she turned her
house into the grinch's whoville
our tree is up you guys know i like a
really simple
flock tree with just twinkle lights
like how pretty you guys if you didn't
think i would
bring back whoville in the house
the kkw beauty founder also admitted
that the whole elf on a shelf thing
wasn't exactly her bag okay so i
couldn't take it anymore because i
forgot to move the elves one night
but she had the perfect solution so
guess who is in quarantine for
10 days they'll be out right before
christmas
this gives mom a 10-day break
i hope they roll with it because
i'm just tired and i can't remember
to move